hello my name is paul
gepford i am a professor at
the university of alabama at birmingham
i'm in the division of infectious
diseases
i've been involved in clinical vaccine
trials since 1997
and in the past year i've been heavily
involved in coded
19 vaccines and i'm a co-chair of the j
j vaccine efficacy study known as
ensemble and i'll talk about that in a
little bit
and i'm very excited to be able to
present to you today
so i'm going to start with a slide that
talks about the vaccine candidates in
development for sars kobe 2 and
obviously this has been wonderfully
successful now
and what i'm highlighting here and you
see this in green
is the ones that are have shown to have
been shown to work
in one way shape or form
and you can see that with the exception
of one
so pfizer and modern are the rna
vaccines novovax and sanofi are the
protein-based vaccines
um the sanofi i won't
talk about too much but they had to go
back and redo their vaccine
uh because it wasn't purified enough and
they're now just getting
back started on that one yet um
astrazeneca
johnson or jnj and sputnik v vaccine
all use this recombinant adeno type
platform that i'll talk about
and cyanovac uses an inactivated viruses
which is one of our oldest technologies
but most of these vaccines with the
exception of sanofi have all been shown
to work in
varying degrees and i'll talk about that
later
so just to back up one thing that we've
known for a long time now
is that antibodies are very important in
protection
for vaccines so the gold standard is
actually what are called neutralizing
antibodies but
you can also induce functional
antibodies to a certain extent as well
however most people in the field think
that neutralizing
antibodies are what you want for a
vaccine to induce
in the person getting vaccinated in
order to prevent
infection um and so what are new and
i'll just say that these uh the polio
measles rabies diphtheria tetanus
neutralizing antibodies are by far and
away the most important correlate of
protection
but then all of these on here uh
are have been shown to be correlated
with protection in terms of just
antibodies alone so that's what we
really wanted to get with these vaccines
to begin with
ideally so neutralizing antibodies what
are they so this is a
diagrammatic representation of that so
you have sars kobe 2 that wants to go
into the cell and what it does
is it attaches to the h2 receptor
the h2 receptor just parenthetically is
on many many cell types and so that's
one of the reasons they believe that
sars kobe 2 and and cobit 19 is such a
devastating disease for some people
because it can attach to many different
cell types
so anyway the virus does that it gets
into the cell and then it does what
viruses do which is make more viruses
inside that cell what neutralizing
antibodies do
is they actually will bind to the virus
and prevent it
from attaching to its cell receptor the
h2
when you can prevent it from doing that
viruses don't last long
unless they go from cell to cell and so
they don't last long and they end up
dying off
and so that's why you can actually
neutralize the virus
with these neutralizing antibodies
and so you can think of neutralizing
antibodies as sort of a spear that it
can kill the virus
upon attachment the other kinds of
antibodies which are just
binding antibodies or functional
antibodies you can look at those as
being a net
that they can sort of keep the virus at
bay but they can't kill it and they need
extra help to kill that virus
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
how mrna vaccines
work because these are the first two
vaccines
pfizer moderna that have been shown to
be effective
in the united states and so
interestingly enough um soros kobe 2
encodes 30 plus different proteins
but we knew from even before cobin 19
that the spike protein is the achilles
heel
of coronaviruses so obviously sars kobe
2 is a type of coronavirus
we have seasonal coronaviruses but we
knew when sarge 1 came about in around
2003
that many studies were done showing that
if you can target the spike protein
that the virus it sort of cripples the
virus
so we knew that very early on and so the
the companies
modern and pfizer knew to use this
protein
another group the nih a guy by the name
of barney graham figured out that if you
can actually
do a certain form of the protein that's
by protein it's even more immunogenic
and induces even better
immune responses and so visor moderna
also used that specific protein that was
highly immunogenic
and what they did was they then very
quickly
got the spike genome the mrna that only
encodes for the spike protein
so then what happens is they just take
that
mrna that encodes the spike protein and
they encase it in a
lipid nanoparticle and the reason they
have to do that is because the
mrna is extremely labile and it probably
is naturally
labile because uh mrna as you probably
know is used by cells
as a genetic template to make proteins
and and it doesn't need it after it
makes the protein and so cells just get
rid of it very quickly afterwards and so
does the environment
um so in order to make this stable they
have to put it in a lipid nanoparticle
and as you know for mrnas they're the
one of the biggest problems with these
vaccines is they require very cold
storage
even with the lipid nanoparticle
so nonetheless you have this lipid
nanoparticle that encases the mrna
and you inject the mrna lipid
nanoparticle
into the arm of a participant
and then in that arm in the muscle uh
there are mainly muscle cells there so
this particle is taken up by the muscle
cells and then muscle cells do what they
normally do which is make
proteins when they're given a genetic
code to make that protein
uh and it'll make proteins uh and
and it'll make in this case the sars
kobe 2 spike protein and so you're using
your own
cells as a protein production factory
which is actually a very ingenious thing
to do because it can be difficult to
make proteins in the lab instead in this
case you're using everybody's own
cells to make proteins so now what
happens
is these proteins that are taken up by
what are called antigen presenting cells
or apc
and these apcs then go to lymph node
and they interact with t cells
and they interact with b cells and the t
cells actually can help the b cells make
really good antibodies
and then these b cells make antibodies
in this case that hopefully will
neutralize sars kobe 2.
what's interesting is these mrna
vaccines can also make t
cells that can actually kill virally
infected cells
and so even if the neutralizing antibody
doesn't necessarily get rid of all
sort of virus before infection even if
the person gets infected
you can have t cells that can sort of
mop up that infection
and so this is ideally what you'd like
for an mrna vaccine i'm also going to
talk about
recombinant adenovirus vaccines and this
is the one from jmj and also astrazeneca
has a vaccine that is also based on
similar technology
so in this case what you use is you used
an adenovirus that is
made replication incompetent so it's
only used as a trojan horse
and inside that trojan horse in this
case you have dna
so the the adenovirus gets into the same
uh muscle cell and it uncoats
and then you have the spike dna and
again cells
in this case have to go from dna to rna
and then the rna makes proteins
and then the same thing happens the
protein then gets taken up by antigen
presenting cells
which go to the lymph node uh and then
the lymph node
the anagen presenting cell interacts
with t cells both
cd4 helper cells and b cells and killer
t cells
and you get the production of hopefully
neutralizing antibodies
and these killer t cells that can mop up
infection
so in essence the mrna vaccines and
these
recombinant adenovirus vaccines really
do work
in the same manner they just do it
mechanistically a little differently
so why is it that these vaccines have
been developed
so rapidly um and the
what i the short story is that they have
all undergone rigorous
safety testing just like most any other
vaccine has undergone
rigorous safety text testing however
what's different about these vaccines
is is that we've been able to rapidly
develop them
because of certain factors and i'll show
those here
so first of all this is the timeline i'm
using the moderna vaccine as an example
so december 31st the chinese reported
coveted for the first time
and 10 days after that they actually
made the sequence
of sars kobe 2 which is the virus that
causes cobit
they made it publicly available and
companies moderna
at the time it took them seven days then
to actually make a vaccine which is
phenomenal
if you use old technology uh
protein-based vaccines it will take you
several months to years to make a
vaccine once even
once you know the actual sequence so
they made it very very quickly
and they tested it in small animal
models and found that it was
immunogenic and it seemed safe in those
small animal models
and so then just a few months later they
did their first
phase one two study first in human study
uh where they tested safety and
immunogenicity
and then what's really important as well
as they got government support so the
government
the u.s government put a lot of money
into the development of moderna
astrazeneca jnj uh novobax and sanofi
vaccines
and this allowed them to rapidly start
efficacy studies
and these were started at the end of
july
uh and middle of july for pfizer as a
matter of fact
um and so then they were able to use
that
and they were able to get some sites
that for free for them they didn't have
to pay for some of the clinical studies
because
again it was government supported the
government gave more money they promised
more money
uh to help them develop the vaccine if
it became an effective vaccine
and then as you know in the middle of
november
this vaccine was shown to be 94
effective and i'll show you that in
preventing coping
uh and then they got approval a month
thereafter uh and
um that's when the vaccine started
rolling out
so why did was it develop so fast just
to reiterate this
we already knew that targeting the spike
protein was extremely important
we also rapidly identified and sequenced
the virus
rna vaccines can be rapidly developed
and so we were very lucky that that
technology was available and ready to
use
there was some very smart
thinking in combining both phases one
and two which
have helped move things along much much
more quickly
the other thing is that we rapidly
enrolled uh
participants and this was a huge
um boost from the community so the
community realized
how important it was to get vaccines and
we had
huge numbers of volunteers that were
volunteers that were ready to go for
these studies
and so we enrolled 30 at least 30 000
people in each one of these studies
and up to 45 000 for the pfizer and j j
studies
and then sadly the other thing is that
we continue to have
huge numbers of new coveted infections
and you need new infections in order to
show that a vaccine worked
and because we had so many it would
allow us to get our answer much more
quickly than we normally would
so those are the reasons and i'll point
out that none of these say that because
we
didn't test them for for safety and i'll
note that the 30 000
individuals that you test for in
efficacy is as much if not more than
most vaccines
have actually tested to become fda
approved
so i'm focusing on now the mrna vaccine
from moderna and this was the phase one
two study and
what this is then is a demonstration
of neutralizing antibodies a graphic
demonstration of that
and so on the on the y-axis you have the
tighter of neutralizing antibody and
obviously the higher up
it is the better the neutralizing
antibody
and on the x-axis you have the different
doses of
vaccine so 25 micrograms to 250
micrograms
and then in this vaccine was given at
day
1 and day 29 and so what you see then
i'm going to focus on the 100 microgram
the one in the middle
is that after the first dose you do get
some amount of neutralizing antibody
but if you compare it to the
convalescent on the right it's less than
the convalescent the convalescent are
people who've recovered from covet
infection
but once you give that one boost the
neutralizing antibodies as you can see
at days 36
43 and 57 are actually higher than
people who've recovered from coving
and so you get better antibodies with
the vaccine than you do with natural
infection
and this has been shown for pfizer as
well uh and several other vaccines
and so that's one of the reasons we
recommend that even if people have
been infected previously with coba they
should still get vaccinated
so at any rate what happened was that
the 100 microgram
dose was the one that was well tolerated
and gave the as good of an immune
response as the higher dose
and better than the lower dose so this
was taken forward to an efficacy study
so how do we do efficacy studies we
vaccinate
uh 30 000 people half of which 15 000
get the mrna vaccine
and the other half get placebo and
importantly it's a randomized
double-blind
study which means that neither the
person giving the vaccine nor the person
receiving the vaccine nor the
investigator
knows what they get so they don't know
if they got the vaccine or if they got
placebo
so they get a couple of injections 28
days apart
and then what happens is you have to
rely on natural exposure
to see what happens and at the end of
uh the period of evaluation you hope
that the people who got the vaccine have
less
cobit than the people who got placebo
so i'll talk about next about the local
adverse events um in this in this
vaccine and what you can see
is that the majority of people had local
adverse events so
any adverse events just focus the one on
the left
that 75 over 75
to 80 percent actually had local pain
uh and then some had erythema swelling
and lymphadenopathy
after the first and second doses however
these were transients
they were generally mild or grade one
and they went away in one or two days
so then we also looked or they also
looked at systemic events
and what you can see is the systemic
events are a little bit more
uh significant in that you can see that
after two doses again the majority of
people had some sort of systemic event
so these things include fever
headaches fatigue things like that
and um the most common ones were
headache and fatigue
uh and you can see that most were
actually mild to moderate
uh and there were some severe but again
the vast majority of these go away
in one or two days and then the
participant had no other further
problems
so next is the efficacy slide uh and the
way
you do these then again is you follow
them over time to see who gets
symptomatic covet pcr positive detected
coping
and in the gray line is the placebo
group and you can see
that on the y-axis that's the cumulative
event of
symptomatic covalent infection and on
the x-axis
it's days since randomization and what
you see is that the placebo group has
much much higher
numbers of coven infection than the mrna
group
shown in blue and you see the arrows
show when the persons
were vaccinated and what's interesting
is you can see the line start separating
before the second vaccine and so
in fact it looks like around 12 to 14
days it starts separating
and you can make that calculation as
well and the vaccine is 90 plus percent
effective
after just the first dose and 95
effective after two doses uh and real
world data is bearing this out as well
so beyond this efficacy study both
moderna
and pfizer vaccines have shown that
after just one dose it's at least
80 percent effective and then 90 plus
percent effective after
two doses
so the next vaccine that i'll talk about
then is the
j and j vaccine this ad 26 kobe 2 point
s
vaccine it also induces neutralizing
antibodies and this is a busy slide this
is their phase one two study again
first in human study where you test
safety and immunogenicity
and what i want to focus on is the low
dose placebo because that's what went on
to
to efficacy studies
so you can see that with the low-dose
placebos
all they get is one low dose of vaccine
and you get
neutralizing antibodies that are shown
there in the sort of the second group of
individuals in the green color
the light green color and what you see
is
that you get a certain amount of
neutralizing antibodies but compared to
hcs which is healthy controls who have
recovered from
covid that you get about the same amount
of antibodies but not
better like we saw with the moderna
vaccine
interestingly if you give two doses you
actually do get higher antibody
responses
but the company made a decision that
because of the we were in a pandemic
that they wanted to be able to just use
the single dose to rapidly
show whether or not this works and
protect against
uh against covet and so
they did the same study and i won't go
belabor this too much but in this case
they enrolled almost 22 000 per arm
just after one injection they looked at
14 to 28 days and then they looked for
efficacy
um so the first thing i'll show you then
is the local events and i want to point
out here that the
local adverse events were actually lower
than with the moderna and
even the pfizer vaccine that i'm not
showing and you can see that younger
people
tend to have higher local events than
older people
but yet they were below 60 percent in
this case for local events
and for systemic events um you can see
that it's less than 60 percent as well
and you can see that the top is the is
the actual vaccine the bottom is the
placebo
uh and when you subtract placebo you can
see that the local events are actually
fairly reasonable we're talking if
you're talking
any adverse event uh in an older
individual
you can see that it's 45 percent but the
placebo is about 35
so only about 10 people had any kind of
systemic event
so the bottom line is this vaccine is
better tolerated than the mrna vaccines
um and then so then now we're looking at
the efficacy and this is the same kind
of data that i showed before
uh and this is any coven infection
so this is vaccine efficacy against any
type of coconut infection
and in this case the blue line is the
placebo the red line is the vaccine
and what you can see then is that in
this case again
after 14 days you got start seeing
separation
of the of the lines meaning that that's
when you start seeing efficacy
and the efficacy continues to increase
and in this situation
it was about 70 percent effective um
so a bit less than the pfizer and
moderna but
that they didn't compare the two so it's
difficult to know
if it's truly uh less efficacious
and then more importantly is vaccine
efficacy against
severe disease and again you see this
what i want to point out is that now you
see separation after seven days on the
left
and the vaccine efficacy against severe
disease was 80 plus percent
after 14 days but then what you can see
then
is that the vaccine efficacy continues
to increase in the graph on the right
and 70 days afterwards um
against severe covet infection it was
nearly 100
effective and what's not shown here is
that
the j j vaccine and actually most all
the other vaccines
are about 100 percent effective against
preventing severe cobalt infection that
requires hospitalization
or leads to death so extremely effective
vaccines
so what the other thing about the gnj
vaccine that was remarkable was it
tested against these emerging
variant strains um including uh
and so it and you can see that the
vaccine efficacy against severe and
critical disease as i mentioned was 80
plus percent
and you can see that in the united
states 86
88 brazil and 82 in south africa
and south africa is a situation where
they have this b
1351 lineage that actually is partly
vaccine resistant
but despite the fact that it's partly
vaccine resistant it was still
82 percent effective in preventing
severe critical
covet and 100 percent of that effective
against hospitalization of death
so this was the first time showing that
even though we have these
potentially problematic viral variants
that still work well against them
so the other thing that a lot of people
ask is well
you're preventing against symptomatic
covalent but are you preventing against
all infections and the reason that's
important is you want to be able to
prevent against subsequent viral spread
in people who don't even know they have
infection and this is some of the first
data but other companies have this now
but jnj was the first to really have
this
and that is that you show that um
that in this situation the j vaccine
prevents
actually asymptomatic or undetected
coping 19.
and what you can see if you look at the
bottom panel that it
actually prevents serial conversion of
zar's cov2 in patients
and participants without any previous
symptoms and it does show in an efficacy
of 75
so not only are these vaccines
preventing against cobalt 19
infection uh where you're symptomatic
but it actually prevents sars kobe 2
infection
outright which is great news for the
world
so this is just a slide showing of what
we have
now in terms of the effective studies
showing efficacy today some of these
have been published some of these have
just been uh given in press releases
but i show them here um you see that the
pfizer modern vaccines
its efficacy rates have been 94 to 95
effective
and in real world data now because these
were the first to come out have shown
that this
is continuing to be state uh this this
good
i will mention parenthetically that
pfizer just this week
reported that their vaccine in 12 to 15
year olds in a small study was
100 effective against preventing
symptomatic coping
and they also did another small study in
south africa with these variant strains
and again it was 100 percent effective
remarkably in preventing
infection against these variant strains
so that's fantastic news
astrogenica and johnson and sputnik v
are all these recombinant adenovirus
vaccines and you can see that their
efficacy rate
varies anywhere from 60 to 90 percent um
and i've talked about johnson's vaccine
and and how it prevents against severe
disease
uh and then this um cyanovac and covaxin
which are two
vaccines one made by china one made by
india
that are using really old technology to
use this inactivated sars kobe 2
and you can see that its vaccine
efficacy varies anywhere from 50 to 78
and there's no data that i'm aware of uh
preventing against
a severe disease but i suspect that it
will as well
so i'm going to end to ask to
try and answer this question which is do
i need to be vaccinated every year and
that is the big
question and the answer is unknown at
the moment
and it's going to depend on the amount
of viral variants that are circulating
in the population
and the duration of immunity
and this slide shows uh just the
back to that old schematic um soros kobe
2
representation and it shows a
representation of the bio viral variants
what they've done is they've made these
viral variants to test them in the test
tube and in the test tube there is a
slight decrease if you see on the wild
type versus this
viral variant which is the one in south
africa which is
somewhat vaccine resistant however what
you see is it's just a slight drop off
and you still do get neutralization to a
certain
event extent i'm sorry um
and i will say that we now have uh
vaccine data from three different
companies pfizer novobax
and um and and jnj
and they show varying vaccine efficacy
i'm sorry in astrazeneca
as well varying x vaccine efficacy
against these variants
the astrazeneca vaccine did very poorly
against this variant about 10 percent
the novovax was 50 effective against
this the
j vaccine was uh 60
65 effective against uh symptomatic
covet and
85 against severe covet and then
as i mentioned the pfizer vaccine was
100 effective against symptomatic
covet infections so um
we'll we'll just have to see if these
variants
take hold in the world if other variants
that are more vaccine resistant take
hold we'll just have to see
and then the other factor is well how
long do these antibodies last that you
get with the vaccine and this data was
published in the new england journal
from moderna
and what you can see is especially in
young people these antibodies continue
to last
at least four months into after
vaccination
they seem to decline maybe a little more
in older people but they're still
present
i will say that pfizer which has a
similar mrna vaccine has
uh efficacy data now six months later
and still highly effective at six months
which is again fantastic news
and so just to include i think the
important thing is
um how is it that common vaccines have
been rapidly developed
being the prior vaccine record by four
years so the measles
facts i'm sorry the mumps vaccine was
developed in five years
which was the prior record and again we
had prior sars
one knowledge that helped us know that
the spike protein was the achilles heel
of the virus and to target that
we had new technology and remember the
mrna vaccine came out and was approved
before we even had
we even started a protein-based vaccine
study
so this new technology helped us as well
neutral design rapid enrollment into
very large trials
and then the growing pandemic was
helpful and then when the
vaccines were studied we had a
relatively low viral mutation
rate and it's important to say that even
though these vaccines have been shown to
be
very effective and safe in these early
studies
we're continuing to look when we start
vaccinating millions of people
for potential vaccine side effects and
to be sure that these vaccines are still
working really well
and with that that's all i have and i
really appreciate your time
thank you